major news coming your way this hour
democrats getting ready for a big night
at their virtual convention
and president trump he's set to hold a
news conference just minutes from now
we're going to have that for you live as
for the democrats they're bringing out
the heavy hitters to go after president
trump and make the case for joe biden
hillary clinton nancy pelosi elizabeth
warren
and former president obama all scheduled
to speak
tonight and the spotlight will be on
senator kamala harris as she officially
accepts her party's nomination
for vice president democrats expected to
keep painting president trump as unfit
for
office while touting biden's character
and leadership
watch this donald trump has divided our
country
diminished our greatness we need a
president with dignity integrity
faced with a president of cowardice joe
biden is a man of proven courage
from the moment president trump took
office he's used
his position to benefit himself rather
than our country
joe's moral compass is always pointed in
the right direction
today we are a country divided and we
have a president doing everything in his
power to make it that way
we just need leadership worthy of our
nation
bret baer welcome to the show you're an
hour early for the fox audience
um so the message is good guy versus bad
guy and today
kamala harris who has that major speech
tonight
said that children american children are
paying the price for trump's
name-calling racism
anti-immigrant rhetoric how do
republicans argue with this
well listen i think tonight is really
about setting the table for kamala
harris and we can just start by saying
it
it's going to be historic i mean it's
the first woman of color on a national
presidential ticket but it'll be
sprinkled with a lot of
anti-trump rhetoric that we've seen over
the past two days
but i think that there's also kind of
this outreach that is going to happen
tonight with elizabeth warren and other
more
progressive or left-leaning figures in
the democratic party because they've
spent two days
talking to moderates and republicans and
i think it's not
sitting well with some progressives
that's a good point
so dana the other side of this is
you have the democrats as i mentioned
bringing out barack obama tonight
they've already heard last night from
bill clinton
jimmy carter uh and they all say you
know
biden's a good guy but what about
where's george bush where's mitt romney
and last night cindy mccain was even
speaking at the dnc
is there absent saying hey we don't back
trump he's not a good guy
where you mean what do you mean where is
george bush first of all
he has said that he's not getting
involved in 2020 politics and he didn't
get involved in 2016 politics so i don't
expect to see him
and mitt romney um as a senator i i i
don't know i don't know where they are
and i don't think it much
matters i do think that there is a
growing concern amongst the progressives
that
joe biden is a guy who's had a lot of
built up a lot of relationships over the
years
and a lot of his relationships are with
his peer group um which is like an older
generation and so
you see a lot of tension i think amongst
the democrats saying
fo we understand that we are against
trump like that's
made been made perfectly clear but what
are we for
and yesterday uh you had alexandria
ocasio-cortez
she laid out what she's for uh bernie
sanders and importantly that what he's
for and they're talking very
specifically about policy
and not about character now will kamala
harris decide to talk more about policy
tonight
i kind of don't think so i think she is
going to be a little bit more
of a broad brush i am interested to see
how she will
address the fact that um she has a past
in law enforcement that she was quite
proud
of and ran on when she ran for senate
but has kind of run away from
uh since the other thing is i believe
that if the
the concern for if you're an undecided
voter would be if you were watching this
so you know that they're against trump
again it's been well established
but what would happen if they were to
win like what's the policy
what's the first step what's the first
thing you want to do when barack obama
was running you knew what it was
and it was healthcare um or and he also
ran on immigration though he decided not
to do that first
on this one it's just pretty much we're
going to restore the country
because we think his character is bad i
i know that they might talk about policy
as well but we'll see the last thing i
would say on this is they've tried to
show that joe biden is quite a
bipartisan guy
and yet tonight you are going to have
speeches from speaker pelosi
and elizabeth warren who i think
democrats would say are quite
obstructionists
and you have pelosi unable to get a deal
done on
coronavirus where you've had mark
meadows the chief of staff of the white
house
out earlier today basically saying
please come with an open heart
a compromising heart we'll we'll work
together we'll try to get this done
we want people to have their money we
want the post office to be able to be
funded
sure enough won't you please come and
join me and i think tonight you'll see
that
she's probably not going to do that so
jesse
the president is out today with some
tweets about goodyear
tire he says the company is not allowing
maga hats and shirts at the
at work but saying it's okay to have
black lives matter gear
the company says the distinction is
between political campaigns and a
message of inclusion
trump is saying double standard what
does jesse say i say nothing the story
goes away in about two hours once the
convention starts and we hit prime time
juan we live in a populist feisty era
and joe biden is just behind the times
the democrats win when they run young
vibrant inspirational characters like a
jfk like a barack obama
like a bill clinton joe biden is 80. and
the message this week from the
democratic national convention is
america's racist
trump is mean and joe will make things
normal again
that's not going to motivate enough
voters to win back the white house
ask a hundred people on the street right
now what joe's slogan is
no one knows that it's billed back
better no one even knows what that means
i went on his website today to find out
what his plan to fight the coronaviruses
guess what i found out joe wants to
accelerate a vaccine
why didn't trump think of that he says
he's going to help the workers well why
doesn't he call his pal nancy and tell
her to stop blocking the checks
he says he's going to test more is he
working on a secret testing kit in his
basement that he's going to reveal after
the election
and to dana's point he says he wants to
unify the country as trotting out
probably the three most polarizing and
divisive and partisan people
in american politics today and i don't
think the attacks against this character
is going to work
this isn't the 90s where we're shocked
at bill clinton's affairs
trump's been a tabloid all-star since
the 80s
and to go after him on compassion misses
the entire reason why he won in 2016
is because he was obsessed with bringing
back the forgotten men and women of this
country
by building the wall by doing new trade
deals
and making america great again that's
what america first is all about
that play can work against a technocrat
that's not relatable like a romney or a
bloomberg
that doesn't really connect with donald
trump and for democrats to play
the empathy card while they watch their
own cities get
shot up and burned kind of make sure you
shake your head
huh all right so greg i know one of your
favorite people
is on deck tonight and that's hillary
clinton now you know that the president
has her used her as a foil
and i wonder if you think it's going to
be more uh trump going after hillary by
tomorrow morning
i know i think bill's just happy she's
not in the house
get some time alone look uh the
democratic strategy is a stool
with three sneaky little legs
number one it's a referendum on
personality from the cool kids in the
cafeteria right if this were high school
everybody you mentioned tonight they're
the mean girls right and trump's the new
kid in town
who didn't fit in he's actually the hero
in the movie so it's not gonna work
number two you definitely gotta blame
him for covid that's your only strategy
except that as dana and jesse pointed
out they've offered no plan
and i've always as i've always pointed
out blue states are suffering way more
death
than red states with fewer cases most
important and to jesse's point number
three the third part of the stool
you got to pretend that the chaos and
the murder in democrat-led
cities do not exist because they helped
sustain it for 80 days
and they're hoping that the chaos scares
enough voters not to vote for trump
because you're thinking about the
ramifications of the consequences if he
wins
could end up being absolutely explosive
if you notice none of these attacks are
based on any kind of data
they can you can't quantify personality
right so these are opinions
but you can measure economy and jobs but
the point is before
covid the economy and jobs these were
historic historic numbers so you can
argue that trump set the table
economically for the country to sustain
and weather
the devastation of kovid's attack so if
you were to bring up the
economy it's actually a problem for you
because that's trump's wheelhouse
and he's proven that he can kick syria's
butt so that is why they're having to
rely on this craziness about blaming him
for this or that or that he's
really really mean and we can't have
mean people in government please spare
me